♪ ♪
>> Greg: IF YOU KNOW ONE THING
ABOUT ME IS THAT I FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE, WHEREVER THE SCIENCE
GOES, I AM THERE.
IF IT HEADS TO THE BAR I WILL
FOLLOW IT AND BUY IT A SHOT.
BUT IF YOU FOLLOW THE SCIENCE
AND THINK IT’S ALWAYS DR. FAUCI
YOU WILL BE CHASING YOUR TAIL
LIKE A BEAGLE WITH OCD, THE MAN
CHANGES HIS STORY MORE OFTEN
THAN A SUSPECT ON COLOMBO.
>> RIGHT NOW AT THIS MOMENT
THERE IS NO NEED TO CHANGE
ANYTHING THAT YOU ARE DOING ON A
DAY-BY-DAY BASIS BUT AS SOON AS
IT BECAME CLEAR THAT THERE WAS
COMMUNITY SPREAD, THEN IT BECAME
CLEAR THAT WE WERE IN REAL
TROUBLE.
>> WHEN WAS THAT?
’S BECAUSE I WAS PROBABLY
TOWARDS THE MIDDLE HAVE AN END
OF JANUARY.
>> RIGHT NOW IN THE
UNITED STATES PEOPLE SHOULD NOT
BE WALKING AROUND WITH MASKS.
PUTTING A MASK ON YOURSELF IS
MORE TO PREVENT YOU FROM
INFECTING SOMEONE ELSE.
AND IF EVERYBODY DOES THAT WE
ARE EACH PROTECTING EACH OTHER.
>> IF ONE MASK IS GOOD, TWO
MASKS ARE BETTER.
>> Greg: MAYBE THREE.
YOU COULD WEAR FAUCI ON THE
BEACH, HE SUCH A FLIP-FLOP.
THE DUMBEST LIE EVER MADE WAS UP
AT THE SCIENCE SETTLED" AND
FAUCI’S RIGHT TO SAY WHAT HE
THINKS IS RIGHT FOR THAT MOMENT,
HE’S NOT BLINDED BY SCIENCE,
JUST SPOTLIGHTS.
IT’S WHEN HE LOOKS BACK AND
OPINIONS REPLACE PRESCRIPTIONS
JUST TO TICKLE THE MEDIA.
REUTERS CLAIMED FAUCI SAID THE
PANDEMIC ARRIVED IN THE U.S.
WHEN THE COMPANY WAS DRIVEN BY
POLITICAL DIVISIONS WHERE
WEARING A MASK BECAME A
POLITICAL STATEMENT.
MAYBE THAT COULD HAVE KILLED
MORE PEOPLE AND THAT’S AN
OPINION AND IT’S AN ODD ONE FOR
A DOCTOR WHO MADE EQUIVOCATION
OVER MASKS AND ART FORM.
YOU COULD SAY WEAR A MASK ALL
THE TIME OR TAKE IT OFF
OUTDOORS, SAY NO TO CLOSING
SCHOOLS THEN YES, YOU CAN SAY
IT’S SAFE TO TRAVEL, THEN IT’S
NOT, YOU CAN SAY VACCINES WILL
RETURN US TO NORMALCY EXCEPT
WITHOUT THE NORMALCY, YOU CAN
SAY ALL OF THIS, HE KIND OF DID.
BUT THIS WAS A NOVEL VIRUS SO
IT’S ALL NOVEL TO HIM AND TO US.
BUT ASSIGNING A DEATH COUNT TO
AN OPINION IS A BIT MUCH
ESPECIALLY WHEN EXPERT OPINION
CHANGED SO MUCH, THE THING ABOUT
COVID, IT KILLED A LOT OF OUR
LOVED ONES BUT NOT OUR MEMORIES
OF THEM OR THE ADVICE WE HEARD
RIGHT AND WRONG.
DANA, JUDGING BY THE
IMPERSONATION I’M DOING I’M
GOING TO THROW SOME TAPE BY A
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, DO YOU
KNOW THAT IS?
>> Dana: BRIT HUME.
>> Greg: BRIT HUME HAS A
THEORY ON FAUCI.
>> THE PROBLEM I THINK WITH
DR. FAUCI IS NOT SO MUCH WITH
HIM IS IS WITH OUR FAILURE AS A
SOCIETY TO RECOGNIZE THAT HE IS
A, AN EXPERT IN A NARROW FIELD.
HE’S AN EPIDEMIOLOGIST, HIS JOB
IS TO FIGHT THIS DISEASE.
HE’S NOT AN EXPERT IN CHILD
PSYCHOLOGY OR CHILDREN’S
EDUCATION, HE’S NOT AN AUTHORITY
ON THE U.S. ECONOMY AND THE
DAMAGE THAT MAY BE DONE DO IT.
HE’S JUST NOT.
>> Greg: IT’S AN INTERESTING
POINT, HE’S GOT ONE LANE, THE
PROBLEM IS WHEN HE’S ASKED TO
COMMENT OUTSIDE THAT LANE.
>> Dana: I THINK THERE’S A LOT
OF DIMINISHING RETURNS THAT IS A
SCIENTIFIC FACT, FOR HIS MEDIA
APPEARANCES, HE IS VERY GENEROUS
WITH HIS TIME IN THE MEDIA LOVE
TO HAVE THEM, HE’S GREAT FOR
RATINGS, PEOPLE LOVE TO WATCH
BUT NOW HE’S EVEN TAKING
INCOMING FROM THE MEDIA THAT IS
LOVED AND BECAUSE THEY ARE LIKE,
WELL, WAIT, THE SCHOOLS ARE OPEN
BUT THEY ARE NOT OPEN, THE
SCHOOLS IN ORDER FOR THEM TO
OPEN AND IT DOES GET YOU INTO A
SITUATION WHERE YOU SOUND
INCONSISTENT AND SOMETIMES
DISINGENUOUS.
SO IF I WERE THERE, IF I COULD
GIVE A LITTLE ADVICE TO THOSE
FOLKS THERE, I DON’T THINK HE
NEEDS TO SAY YES TO EVERY SINGLE
INTERVIEW, HE COULD DO, YOU
KNOW, EVEN IF THEY DID ONE
BRIEFING A DAY I THINK THAT
WOULD BE FINE.
I THINK IT WAS GOT EARLY ON, HE
WAS WILLING TO GO ON SOME OF
THOSE PODCASTS AND DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT YOU HADN’T SEEN
DR. FAUCI DO BEFORE AND THAT WAS
AWFUL IN THE BEGINNING BUT NOW
THERE’S WAY TOO MUCH MEDIA, HE’S
WATERED DOWN THE MESSAGE,
CONFUSE THE MESSAGE AND I THINK
THAT EVEN HE WOULD PROBABLY
AGREE WITH THAT THAT STEPPING
BACK FROM ALL OF THESE MEDIA
APPEARANCES WOULD HELP ALL OF
US.
>> Greg: WAND, SHOULD FAUCI BE
IMPEACHED?
>> Juan:>> Juan: [LAUGHS]
NO, YOU KNOW, I’VE GOT TO TELL
YOU I THINK I’M ACTUALLY, YOU
KNOW JUST IN RESPONSE TO DANA, I
THINK HAVING FAUCI OUT THERE,
THE AUDIENCE IS STILL THERE ON
THE MESSAGE IS SO IMPORTANT,
GETTING VACCINATIONS, GIVING
PEOPLE --
>> Dana: YOU DON’T THINK HE’S
IN A SITUATION NOW, TO GREG’S
POINT, THERE ARE INCONSISTENCIES
INCONSISTENCIES.
>> Juan: I THINK GREG MADE A
GOOD POINT BUT IT’S NOT THAT
THERE ARE INCONSISTENCIES, IT’S
THAT AS GREG SAID, THE SCIENCE
EVOLVED.
SO FAUCI SAYING BACK IN MARCH
AND APRIL, HEY, LISTEN, YOU
DON’T NEED TO WEAR A MASK AND IT
TURNS OUT HE WAS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE STOCKPILE OF MASKS FOR
PEOPLE IN HOSPITALS AND THE
LIKE, OKAY, BUT THEN HE WAS
SAYING WEAR A MASK, BY APRIL AND
MAY AND JUNE AND IT WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO WAS SAYING
HE’S NOT GOING TO WEAR A MASK,
IT WAS PRESIDENT TRUMP MOCKING
JOE BIDEN, NEVER SEEN A MASKS IT
SO BIG, MAKING FUN OF REPORTERS
WEARING MASKS AND HE CERTAINLY
KNEW BY THEN WHAT WAS GOING ON.
WHAT STRIKES ME TODAY AS IT’S
NOT DR. FAUCI, IT’S FRANCIS
COLLINS, THE DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE WHO SAID, YOU
KNOW, TRUMP POLITICIZED MASKS,
HE MADE IT A STATEMENT OF YOUR
POLITICAL AFFILIATION,
DECLARATION ABOUT PERSONAL
FREEDOM.
>> Dana: WHAT ABOUT THE
OPENING OF SCHOOLS?
>> Juan: I THINK IT’S BEEN
VERY CLEAR THAT, YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE TO OPEN SCHOOLS BUT WE HAVE
TO DO IT SAFELY.
>> Dana: THEY SAID SCHOOLS
COULD BE OPEN, THE CDC DIRECTOR
SAID SCHOOLS COULD BE OPEN, THEN
THEY SAID SHE WAS SPEAKING IN A
PERSONAL CAPACITY AND THEY
WANTED X AMOUNT MONEY MORE FOR
THE STIMULUS BILL AND THAT’S
WHAT ENDED UP HAPPENING AND THEN
THEY SAID, WE NEED TO GET THE
SCHOOLS OPEN, YOU HAVE TO HAVE
THE STIMULUS BILL, SORRY, I’VE
SPOKEN MORE THAN I USUALLY DO.
>> Greg: YOU WERE SMOKING
WHAT, DANA?
JESSIE, THERE’S A NEAT LITTLE
TRICK AND YOU SAW IT THERE WITH
JUAN, WHEN SOMEBODY STATES AN
OPINION THEY DON’T LIKE IT’S A
POLITICAL, THEY ARE MAKING MASKS
POLITICAL AND WITH TRUMP, THAT
WAS POLITICAL UNTIL THE EXPERT
SAID YEAH, THAT WAS A GOOD MOVE.
SO IT’S LIKE, ANYTHING THAT YOU
DO, YOU POLITICIZE THE TOPIC BUT
THEY DON’T.
>> Jesse: OR IF THEY FLIP-FLOP
THEY ARE NOT FLIP-FLOPPING, THEY
ARE EVOLVING BECAUSE THE SCIENCE
HAS EVOLVED.
MASK SHAMING WHICH FAUCI IS
INVOLVED TO INVOLVED IN IS SO
DEMOCRATS CAN BLAME TRUMP
SUPPORTER’S FOR THE PANDEMIC
INSTEAD OF CHINA, WE SAW HALF A
MILLION PEOPLE DIED DURING A
PANDEMIC IN WHICH HE WAS THE
COUNTRY’S TOP INFECTIOUS DISEASE
DOCTOR AND TRUMP FOLLOWED ALMOST
EVERYTHING HE RECOMMENDED.
A LITTLE BIT OF THIS IS ON BLAME
SHIFTING, I WENT BACK AND LOOKED
AT THE POLLS IN OCTOBER BEFORE
THE SECOND WAVE ON MASK WEARING,
90% OF THE COUNTRY PUTS A MASK
ON BEFORE THEY LEAVE THE HOUSE,
89% OF CONSERVATIVES PUT A MASK
ON BEFORE THEY LEAVE THE HOUSE.
SO, IF 90% OF THE COUNTRY IS
WEARING A MASK, WHY DO WE HAVE A
SECOND WAVE?
AND WHY DID CASES AND DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA EXPLODE WHEN ALL THE
LIBERALS PUT ON MASKS, MASKS ARE
NOT A SILVER BULLET SO TRY STOP
TRYING TO EXPLAIN THE 9% OF
ALLOWED ANTI-MASTERS OUT THERE
THAT DIDN’T CAUSE THE PANDEMIC.
>> Greg: GOOD POINT AND IF WE
WANT TO TALK ABOUT
POLITICIZATION OF A TOPIC,
PROBABLY THE MOST REPULSIVE
POLITICAL ACT WAS NANCY PELOSI
WITHHOLDING AID TO AMERICANS IN
ORDER TO BEAT TRUMP.
THAT’S PRETTY HARSH.
>> Dagen: STANDING ATOP THE
SUFFERING BECAUSE SHE THINKS IT
MAKES HER LOOK TALLER, THE
SUFFERING OF AMERICANS BECAUSE
IT MAKES HER MORE POWERFUL IS
DISGUSTING, I WANT TO PICK UP ON
DANA’S POINT REALLY QUICKLY,
FAUCI DID SAY, WE NEED TO PASS
THE STIMULUS TO OPEN SCHOOLS
WITHOUT MENTIONING THAT 90% OR
MORE OF THE $68 BILLION
ALLOCATED LAST YEAR FOR K-12 OF
SCHOOLS HADN’T EVEN BEEN SPENT,
HE DIDN’T EVEN MENTION THAT SO
CLEARLY HE IS CARRYING WATER FOR
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, FROM
THE OUTSIDE LOOKING IN IT LOOKS
LIKE SOMEBODY IN THE
ADMINISTRATION SAID, HEY, TONY,
EASE UP ON THE GOOD NEWS UNTIL
WE PASS THIS STIMULUS BILL, YOU
KNOW, GO OUT THERE AND SCARE
PEOPLE.
I JUST WANT TO RAISE THIS, IS
SOMEBODY BORN IN A CRAVEN,
PARTISAN HACK OR DO YOU BECOME
ONE BEING AROUND ALL OF THESE
INSUFFERABLE SYCOPHANTS DOWN IN
WASHINGTON?
IS THIS SOMETHING YOU CAN CATCH?
MAYBE TONY FOUND SHE COULD GET
ON THAT AND FILL US IN, HACK.
>> Greg: HE WOULD TELL YOU TO
WEAR A MASK AND THEN NOT TO WEAR
A MASK AND THEN HE WOULD GRANT